hey everybody and welcome to a
sensational wild ride with stevo that's
right the island boys are just that a
sensation i was looking forward to
speaking with them and they they really
kind of blew me away with how juicy
their prison stories are both of them
and frankly i was
honestly impressed by their freestyle
they just kept going and it sounded
pretty cool
also
uh man they were talking about
like
safety
from
being robbed and stuff with all the
jewelry they're wearing and it got me
thinking about
safety of my online activity which is
why i'm so glad this episode is brought
to you by nordvpn
not only does it make you completely
uh
secret about your location it also
allows you to access all kinds of
content from other areas of the world
like for example do you know that
netflix in england has all kinds of
shows that you can't watch in america
unless you're on nord vpn plus you don't
have people snooping around with your
bank info and all that stuff you're
going to go to nordvpn.como
or use the promo code stevo you get a
huge discount on your plan plus free
threat protection plus a month free and
it's risk free with nord's 30 day money
back guarantee i'm telling you i love it
you're gonna love it so go to
nordvpn.com stevo
and get this deal
now let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen the island boys yo
yo yo what's up yeah dude how are you
doing steve oh doing great man thank you
guys for doing this so
uh
we've got kodiak red no i'm cudio red
he's fly okay comment the fly guy the
bird yeah that's how you gonna tell i
have a bird a bald eagle and i guess i
got a 17 in the middle of my forehead so
i'm flying
so yeah i'm so dumb i'm thinking okay
he's got the ego so
fraternal twins meaning you're not
identical twins but you're right
what's that how do you know we're
fraternal done his research yeah i did a
little bit of research now i gotta say
i'm fascinated by you guys oh appreciate
you i really am and
uh
paul is being into music and and as we
got ready to do this with you he
looked up the studio version of this
phenomenal like what you guys were
singing in the pool where the i'm an
island boy
and the [ __ ] studio version of that
song's badass oh the original song yeah
like yeah you should see a new music
video trina song tops island boy yeah
way better good yeah yeah i checked out
trina too
the beat is really cool our music is
getting our music is getting a lot
better yeah we just keep practicing and
working in the studio all the time so
when musicians are like i'm doing a
youtube video is that youtube or is that
or a music video is that youtube or mtv
or like where when they start doing a
music video where does it go this video
goes to okay so how it works is you
streaming all platforms on audio and
then youtube is visuals
so yeah right just like this podcast
test yes right but when you guys are
doing a music video you're like the
intention is to be on youtube
yes because
what exactly are you asking well i'm
just saying because like back in the day
i remember like mtv you know it's like
i'm doing a music video you watching
everything and tv used to have a lot of
music videos uh on there and i don't
even even know if mtv still does that i
don't think i'm part of scott i'm not
talking
about
i don't listen to much
50 cent does the music videos you like
i'm putting this on youtube it's my
platform
it's kind of like if you want to go on
cole bennett uh thing like is that what
you're talking about like lyrical
lemonade if you want a video uploading
that's like the new the new age like if
you want to go on cole bennett or a
world star which
you know i don't know if it's worth it
but i mean you know but cole ben is
definitely worth it we worked with
colbert and he's very
very very serious about it and so that's
like an exclusive release of your video
before it goes on youtube it'll only
live in this one place for a while like
wait wait what is it he said cold
bennett
um you never heard him uh lyrical
lemonade no
wow he's big on youtube well okay he
shot he shot post malone okay
um who else nelly with uh mixed
personalities with kanye west so you're
saying that this is a youtube channel no
i'm just saying we worked we worked with
him so i'm just saying like instead of
mtv i don't know we're new age rappers
so like if you want to you know pay the
extra buck you go on lyrical lemonade
and ah but if you if you want to be
monetized and have because you won't be
monetized on someone else's youtube
channel but you get recognition so it's
either you pick you want to get the
royalties or you want to get the
recognition yeah right was it like van
halen getting paid to be on mtv back in
the day or i don't think so i think that
was just marketing publicity yeah but in
any case you worked with mtv before yeah
my uh career started at mtv oh okay okay
is mtv still the same how it used to be
i mean cheap yeah
but uh you know i wanted to say that
that we listen to the song like the
actual song in the studio and i'm not
trying to just kiss your guy's asses
like i really thought that was that i
said to paul i said dude that song's
dope thank you i think we get a lot of
uh hate like um from it uh we got a lot
of hate from just making music in
general for like us being ourselves and
stuff like that i guess because we're
like kind of different they don't see
twins you know cuban twins or whatever
you probably think we're just like with
some whatever white boys suburbs or
whatever we're just trying to fit in
but this is this has been us our whole
life sure man i don't i don't doubt it
before the clout 4 money or anything
like that right and uh
the the interesting thing about it is
that it wasn't the studio version of
that song that that blew up it was just
the the hot talk video versus swimming
pool yeah it was i think i think it's
fun i think it was the setting it was a
fun environment it was right just in the
jacuzzi you see two twins i'll do
another first down
freestyle raw
raw voice no auto tune and uh they're
like this is catchy it went crazy right
it absolutely went crazy and everyone
was like
i woke up and i was like i'm an island
boy and i'm like
who's an island boy
right i'm like we're all southern island
all of a sudden i'm like okay we didn't
think it was going to blow up like that
we thought the spanish song who dropped
five freestyles on tick-tock and we
thought this better song was going to
blow up but the island boy did and i
didn't i thought it was trash at first
but i liked it i laughed at it he
laughed at me i came up with the idea
and i'm like but i like tropical vibes
you know i want to take a trip to hawaii
you know i want to take trips to like
you know bora boro like when i get rich
and famous like really really yeah
he told me bro just listen to me bro
just go with the island boy thing right
and i'm like laughing and i said i said
i'm gonna respect him because he's my
twin brother and we're like
we work together right so i'm like i'm
respect i'm a freestyle to it so of
course i'm gonna take it serious when i
freestyle right sure so it just i went
with it and everything like that and he
was right the island boy thing was he he
swear to god he said i was gonna go
viral and they did go back right and and
i mean and clearly a lot of people saw
that found it to be funny clowning on it
and hating on it oh yeah i loved it did
you see the people like dressed up as oh
my god dude i saw some of that [ __ ] the
guy who had like the styrofoam [ __ ]
people still people still doing that to
this day the poor noodles [ __ ] no i i
i was talking to him the other day he
still does it to this day he still does
it today that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] did
you see the old lady in the bathtub i
don't know i don't think i saw that one
you saw when they put the deer
i don't i don't know about it i saw that
they made a whole deer they looked at
the antlers
but here's the thing like
you got people clowning on you you got
people hating on you
but at the same time
that that [ __ ] that's what blew you up
you capitalize off of whatever you want
to capitalize on
right when i asked tommy lee i was like
how do you know when you blew up he's
like when people started hating on me
that's when i knew i was big who's tommy
tommy lee from molly crew
i don't i didn't i mean but that's i
don't know who he is but that's facts
yeah crazy yeah right so can you explain
what tommy lee is cause i was just going
through his thing i i knew the people
some of the people that he uh like he
had podcasts with
uh but who's tommy lee tommy woods
there is the drummer of a band called
motley crew also he's a rock he's a rock
star he's a big time rock star i'm into
i'm into the rock [ __ ] yeah big time
rock star from the 80s 90s
yeah but does he still perform yeah
you've seen that and they're they're
going on a stadium tour uh this year did
you see this big show tommy and pam he
was married to pamela anderson no i have
not seen is that an actor
it's an actor playing him yeah yeah he
had a famous sex tape where he had sex
with his wife
it's real it's a real sex tape yeah like
in the 90s when the internet first came
out like it was the first sex tape so
it's an old sex tape
is the first one that's that's kind of
golden yeah it's epic it's it's it's a
fascinating story
um so
like
what i saw
about you guys and your music career was
that you started recording music in
uh 2020 yes to just that that quick that
quick yes
yeah so you started recording music in
2020
the uh seriously seriously we started
recording music right now because i want
to be a rapper for a while for a while
but we we doubted ourselves because
people betrayed us and they like you
know laughed at us and it takes
to be an artist it's like it's a lie
you know how hard it is to like invest
in like like you know how you got to
invest in your career you know what i
mean your dream and stuff like that how
hard it was for us like 17 year olds to
try to like follow because we're young
we're 20 right now and especially when
you don't have no one supporting you
yeah no one's supporting you
i came out of jail i tatted my whole
face my whole neck and stuff like that i
didn't have a job so we we had we we had
uh each other's back and stuff like that
yeah you know motivate each other so
that's good that i have a twin brother i
have a twin brother that has the same
dream and ambitions you know so we're
we're alike you know
yeah it's crazy how we came out the womb
thinking of like like career-wise you
know we have the same path even though
we have some disagreements but we we
settled them and stuff like that but um
it's business business but we also you
know brotherly love you know what i'm
saying so sure yeah she she started
recording music in 2020 right and before
that you said when you got out of jail
when did you get out of jail uh i want
to say it was 2019 2019 20
2019 2018 2019 transition around there
so that was just straight juvenile
man get ready to be really happy that
you're not in prison when i heard these
crazy stories these guys told about
being on the inside locked down i was
real happy to be a free man and you know
what else makes me really happy the way
i am killing it with my e-commerce dude
if you haven't figured out that in this
day and age everybody can have their own
thriving business selling stuff online
then it's time for you to figure out
ship station because that is what makes
it possible that's how i'm selling so
many of these awesome autographed b
skateboards because dude ship station
gives you access to the best shipping
rates which are normally reserved for
like fortune 500 companies i'm talking
every carrier u.s post office ups dhl
whatever it is man it's all integrated
into one system and it doesn't matter if
your business is using amazon etsy your
own website whatever it is it is the
most simple interface where everything
is just made super easy
and
get this you can have a 60 day free
trial absolutely free if you go to
shipstation.com and then you click the
microphone in the top right hand corner
type in the promo code stevo and that's
right you got 60 days that's two months
of totally stress free
shipping with the best rates and i'm
telling you your business can take off
just like mine did so make ship happen
get your ecommerce game thriving with
shipstation one more time it's
shipstation.com
click the microphone in the top right
corner use the promo code stevo and 60
days absolutely free and you can become
a budding businessman like the island
boys let's get back to them
yes i was i was i they sent me uh to
duvall county uh you know jacksonville
sure yeah so they sent me to do a county
all the way from palm beach and i did
like two years it was it was pretty
serious we were we were labeled as
medicine societies because
when you're juveniles they'll give you
slapping a wrist and um you know when
you're a kid and you're running wild you
know you're a little alive so i turned
21 i'm still delinquent so oh so they
sent you to jacksonville because they
didn't want you guys to be in the same
spot because you cannot no you can i
can't be in the same mod the same dorm
right why because you're related yeah
yeah you could i mean they consider a
game i mean you could jump you could
jump some people yeah
right yeah you can team up yeah so
that's why they sent you to jacksonville
and you know that's not why uh basically
it's like it's like the same thing as an
adult where you sit down a county and
they when you get sentenced they send
you to prison so basically i sat down in
a juvenile detention center waiting
waiting for it i did that time i get no
time served and then what's it called
because i i literally the day i got
committed because that's what you get
sentenced as juvenile they consider
committed the day i got committed they
passed the law where you cannot get
you can't get released home and wait to
to wait till you uh go up the road so
you had a city you can't get no house
arrest that's not yet to sit so you had
to sit down and wait until you get
transferred to the program that you're
supposed to go to and then that's when i
put those on everything i'm not lying
i'm the one that sat the most out of
everybody i did seven months dead time
in juvenile detention
everybody asked me
everyone kept telling me you sat here
the mo the longest in in here and i'm
like why they're like they just keep red
flagging because you keep getting your
fights you keep going to comply but i
didn't really believe that i'm like
that's a myth they just don't want me to
well getting in fights when you're in
custody is not really yeah it's not it's
not a good idea but you could get in
fights in there yeah and do without
attention now when they send you to a
gram it's called a grand when they send
you like a juvenile prison when in duval
when they say that you catch time for
fighting
i remember being in jail in florida i
was in jail in orlando
orlando orlando was a tough
spot
it was it was 10 days
that i was sentenced to for my second
dui and i did all 10 days
and i remember like they they had us in
like a big [ __ ] like gymnasium with
all bunk beds there would have been a
hundred [ __ ] open bay open bay yeah i
didn't know orange county i didn't know
which county is open it was 1996 had to
have been 100 bunk beds 1996 and if you
[ __ ] around
yeah if
you [ __ ] around have you gotten any
trouble this guy's been around for a
while yeah i'm old if you got any
trouble they would say
pack your things you had like a little
[ __ ] uh like uh not not a mat it was
like a a bus boy a bus boy bin
you know like a plastic bin yeah they
would say pack your [ __ ] no it's a
little too big you're going to know
whether they see you're going to go down
to like the dungeon or whatever and the
implication was
that you because you couldn't even take
a piss without being on camera
everything was on camera even in the
bathroom yeah even in the bathroom even
in the bathroom and if you got in
trouble then pack your things meant
you're going down into like the dungeon
where presumably everything isn't okay
you're like cool i get the jerk off now
no i saw a camera right in the corner it
was like a little camera it's it's like
hidden and i'm like i'm gonna jerk my
dick off right on camera and then i'm
gonna rap right after yeah i know in the
comments and the combination that had a
camera but not in uh not gonna find it
yeah yeah but in the regular cells they
didn't have a camera but confinement
there's people that don't care those are
called yeah but steven let me ask you a
question as crazy as you are when you
were in jail
how did that feel were you were you
going crazy
um i mean it was only ten days it was
only ten days did you know was getting
did you know he was getting out well i
can't lie i i knew that i was gonna get
sentenced
to some time because there was no way of
me saying i didn't drunk i wasn't drunk
driving i mean they got me yeah they got
me good it was my second
drug driving didn't you say you got me
what are you doing yeah that was my
first dui so he got me the second one i
tried to kind of put up a fight but but
it wasn't gonna work and uh
what it was was i i lived in like
around uh like boca raton i was west
palm beach area
and i had gotten arrested while i was at
a skateboarding convention in orlando
and and yeah i was
drunk as a [ __ ] and so i had to
go back to orlando for my arraignment
and i just said hey man like i could
barely afford the [ __ ] greyhound bus
to get to orlando i don't want to go
back and then back and forth and back
and forth i showed up to my arraignment
and i asked for permission to plead
guilty right away and go straight into
jail to just get it all done in one trip
in just 10 days 10 days they told you it
was 10 days yeah they're talking 10 days
and and i want to take nothing over too
sit down i'm not saying i
you know
so when you came out how did you feel
well i was stoked as hell because they
uh they let me have
paper and a pencil and i started writing
my [ __ ]
i wrote jailhouse memoirs i wrote my
script were you steve all the time i did
the the first [ __ ] thing i wrote on
my first page was hello
they call me stevo
but i'm thinking about switching back to
stephen steve glover because i've kind
of begun a career now and i don't know
if i want a nickname when i'm famous
that's the first [ __ ] [ __ ] i wrote
and that's your opponent
my real name is steven glover yeah
i ended up like
you know doing a show and they were i
called myself stevo and the crowd was
chanting stevo and so so what what got
you big exactly because i used to watch
you as a kid but i used to look at you
like a stunt double like you know yeah
not a stunt double i was just a stunt
[ __ ]
so like
i would see you get like like uh you
know shot in the ass
yeah i did a bunch of dumb ass [ __ ] we
went a show on mtv and we ended up
making it into movies and stuff and and
and that all began in year 2000 yeah now
it's
so it's been 22 years i bet your ass has
a whole bunch of scars from bb yeah he's
getting shot
can i ask you a question i saw a video
you're getting punched by what ufc
fighter in the stomach
oh i didn't get punched by a ufc fighter
in the stomach i think that i'd have
been somebody else is that when he broke
his nose on mike tyson's fist
man you got punched in the stomach at a
hotel room
i don't i don't think that was that was
me that doesn't ring a bell
oh okay yeah but but in any case man i
i've been at it for a long time i've
been in jail a bunch of times
and uh you know and and i get it
um you said you were you you were down
in the juve for two years he was too
bothered i just did a little bit more
time because i i because you had the
aggravated with the firearm no i didn't
i did oh you had the aggravated that was
when i was an adult though yeah that's
what he was in though i mean that's a
gnarly one
damn firearm i mean i beat the charge
yeah but i'll get it i mean i i yeah i
mean somebody tried to try them in miami
you know how it is someone tried trying
to miami south beach and i said where
you at and pull up and i put a gun i
said it was a six foot tall guy with a
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna he did that
for me because i told him i'm like yo
somebody's trying to fight him i said
okay so i'll pull up and i put the red
beam on you once you know they got
scared and they ran and he ran to the
police and they called the cops red beam
that's just creepy
a six foot tall guy i would have anybody
would have known he's six feet tall i
would run too no no he was bigger than
you yeah there is nothing [ __ ] about
running from a red beam
on your forehead
and he was a gangster and he went police
yeah i mean hey dude you you know you
know i bonded out the same night my bomb
was high as [ __ ] you know it's three of
them right those three one
yeah they ran like a [ __ ] my bomb was
high as [ __ ] and i was sitting in miami
and trk it's like that it was around
this time actually like spring break
there were tourists i know they and i
had and i and um i'm sitting there i'm
like man you know i got all these
tattoos at the time already i'm like i
look like a celebrity one one staff
tried to call me a six nine i said don't
call me no [ __ ] six nine six nine and
huh what's six nine six nine
yeah she tried to call me to six nine
and she and she threw me in confinement
because i caught her [ __ ] so when she
threw me in confinement i'm freezing
cold i'm shirtless with all my tattoos
and i said i i prayed and i said i am
never going back in here and then one of
the staffers says hey man i like you man
come on come on real quick i'm gonna
take you out of confinement [ __ ] what
she's talking about and uh let me let's
get you up we're gonna put you all the
way upstairs and stuff like that put you
dressed up i'm like hey listen i'm just
trying to get bonded out he's like what
did you do your but your bond's pretty
high and i'm like did you did you shoot
no i'm like no i did not any time your
charge starts with the word aggravated
yeah that's bad and i knew it and i and
i knew him so
remember i asked the cop i asked cop so
how many times did you charge me with
aggravated assault he she said one time
and then i go in there and they said
they charged me twice and i said oh okay
there's aggravated assault with a
firearm and then there was like
improperly showing a weapon or something
there was some weird [ __ ] it was pretty
it's pretty serious what does the word
aggravated mean in this aggravated means
like
like it's a violence
there's aggravated homicide there's like
it's like sort of like just like
you know you you did you you went all in
yeah everybody outside yeah yeah
yeah but it was it was a self-defense it
was a self-defense thing i mean the guy
was trying to uh fight him and stuff
like that i mean like are you trying to
fight you keep forgetting as a group
there's a group of people people trying
to die
trying to jump him and i'm like i'm like
i'm like bro you're not going to jump
him well i'm glad to be i'm glad you
beat the i'm glad you beat the charge
it's so funny because his charges were
way more serious his lawyer was cheaper
and he he he beat that he beat those
charges and then the other one that i
got charged with
[ __ ] the other one i got charged
with was false
had uh you know i wouldn't be surprised
if it had something to do with the the
people
yeah they called the cops at first but
they probably didn't stick around to
come cooperate in court no right right
yes yes you're right they weren't they
you're right about that okay i told you
they're from a different state you're
right about that right i told them don't
worry i'm like they're not gonna even
testify they're not gonna do it so
um like i feel like [ __ ] around with
guns and you know like i mean do you
believe in guns i i i don't give a [ __ ]
i i
i feel like
the the
i think the statistics show that of the
people who get shot
most of them get shot with their own gun
so i feel like the uh like committee
luther
committing suicide or like justin
if someone else gets someone else takes
their gun and shoots them with that
that's a that's a dummy with a gun is
florida is florida open carry
florida's pretty gun you can like walk
around the gun on your hip in florida
like arizona i mean i don't know yeah
florida's pretty downward tax you seen
texas
no yeah no you but you have to have a
you have to have a consider there's two
different licenses in florida uh for you
to have uh open carry there's an open
carry and then there's a concealer okay
legally yes you're allowed to have a
firearm at the house
yeah but uh uh to have an open carry to
go outside with it on your waist you're
gonna have a lot of different type of
lights for that right and it's annoying
because right now covey with the classes
and stuff
my belief is that
by
purchasing a gun by owning a gun by
carrying a gun you dramatically increase
your chances of dying
from a gunshot wound i agree
so i'm not really particularly
interested in being shot and so i just
avoid guns
unless you're filming it but you need it
right well yeah i have some stuff coming
up that i'm going to do with that but
there but that's but that's for one but
you need but you need it but you need a
gun for safety though
i gotta say i am personally not sold on
the idea that guns contribute to safety
or overall well-being but one thing that
i am positive contributes to overall
well-being is athletic greens now
admittedly my diet is in the toilet i
relapsed on sugar i'm a little blubbery
these days but the one thing saving me
is that i'm using my athletic greens
every day what is athletic greens well
it is comprehensive convenient daily
nutrition and it happens to be delicious
one of these packets is all i need i
wake up in the morning dump it into a
pint of water and guzzle it down and
it's
loaded with
75 different vitamins
minerals whole food-sourced superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens there's so
much good nutritious stuff in here that
i actually think i might be getting away
with eating donuts and all the other
crap because at least i'm covering my
bases with athletic greens and it helps
my gut health it helps my cognitive
thinking my brain health dude this stuff
is a godsend i love it and if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo not only will you get five of
these packs for free you will also get
an entire year supply of vitamin
d which boosts your immunity and your
overall health i'm telling you that is a
sweet deal with your first purchase at
athleticgreens.com
stevo jump on it and feel better look
better
be better athletic greens yeah dude now
back to the guns
so just keep in the safe and don't play
with it i i get that i get that i
understand it and what if a guy comes in
your house one day he goes he's like oh
you got money this net you know
especially as a rapper stuff like that
and what's it called you flash this
diamonds all this this that and then
someone tries to pop out of your house
you gotta shoot them ah yeah before the
stand your groundwork i go out of my way
to make my house unappealing for
robberies
you know like and how you did that
security i mean it's it's about like
you know if i have some valuables have
them in the safe deposit box at the bank
where you know like if you have money
like what if someone maybe
what if someone wants to harm you though
harm you yeah
i mean
that isn't a farm to himself i don't
know
he's like what do you guys want to do
okay hold on let me do that myself are
we filming i hurt myself more you know
like uh i don't know i mean
knock on wood i i've done i think a
pretty good job of not making myself a
target to people yeah yeah you did and
so like i don't know i i i
i don't draw attention to my house i
don't leave valuables sitting around in
my house so like there's not a lot of
reason do you even have a lot of people
that come to your house
i don't like it man i've had fans show
up and and uh that's when i get grumpy
like i'm pretty cool with everybody it's
your house you don't want people like
man
like i i deal with people everywhere i
go all day long and i'm generally cool
to everybody everywhere right but when
i'm at my house that's it's it's not
yeah it's like yesterday like i'm in my
i'm in my my room my room's got like
like french doors windows and then
there's kids in the back in my my
lakefront there's kids they sneak around
they're taking videos and stuff like
island boy i'm like oh no i'm not coming
outside for that it's it's just like you
know like it's it's
it's my spot you know like i don't
[ __ ]
you know there are like few things that
are sacred in this world and it's your
house and not taking photos with people
while you eat you know i think that's
right yeah
have you seen people that take like
videos of them on tik tok live like like
eating like noodles
asmr people really like watching people
eat yeah people love that [ __ ] do people
bother you guys a lot because you guys
are recognizable from like half a mile
away you know like like when we was just
eating people were asking for pictures
and stuff yeah that was it happened the
chef treated us good nice good yeah i
mean dude i gotta say dude you guys have
been on a lot of big podcasts that and
you know it seems universally you come
off very likable
like you i don't know why i think it's
because we're young i don't know why
people like some people consider us as
like intimidating or threat or whatever
it isn't that there's something to do
you know or some people get money
whatever it is i i but there's a lot of
people with money so yeah but those
people aren't hating on you huh they're
not
right it's people that are broke they're
like [ __ ] these guys yeah yeah that's
true that's true that's true
you gotta understand people thought we
wasn't gonna make it like people thought
people were like laughing at us when we
first like started they were like look
at these clowns with face tattoos until
you make it and then they're all like
dude we knew you would blow up but it's
not like that when you blow up they stay
quiet they stay quiet it's like where
they were at like you know they doubted
us and stuff like that and it's not like
i'm gonna be like ha ha i made a whole
bunch of money it's in your face yeah i
don't care i gotta go let's still doubt
you one thing i learned is you can never
prove it hater wrong yeah that's true
you drive a lamborghini that's ranting
dude you got girls she's renting yeah
the only thing you could prove is to
prove to yourself and that's all you
know never going to prove a hater wrong
you can't negotiate with crazy but don't
ever give up and don't let no one ever
get to your head you know i like that i
follow you guys on tick tock you guys
introducing the third person well i'm
trying to make him into a rapper yes
yeah what's his name trello
and is he fire or what um i'm working on
it i mean he does he's not like he's not
like us we we we put a lot of work in
he's he's got it easy man we put him on
yeah he's he's got to find a little bit
more confidence he's got a little more
confidence yeah i thought he was shy i
mean i'm not having [ __ ] at all yeah
when you guys are like well we're
helping him out it's just it's it's a
lot to it you're not the only one that's
noticing he's a little shy
look in in in in in this type of
industry in the game it's like it's like
you gotta you gotta take risks man you
know you gotta put your foot forward and
you gotta really put all that all that
pride to the side or whatever you're shy
or whatever the case might be it's not
what it's about man you know if you
wanna make it you gotta make it man you
gotta you gotta be dedicated and you
gotta you gotta put your heart and soul
to it you gotta wake up and be that
person
yeah
i mean coming from juvia it's like
it's not even juvie man i mean yeah
juvie opened up my eyes and i grew up a
lot you know when i see when i was in
juvenile i was lost and i was pissed off
because i had a lot of fake people
around me when i when i was in there it
wasn't all about fighting people in
there so like that i did a lot of soul
searching so i learned myself a lot and
i learned i would look at myself in the
mirror i'm like man you know like i
don't have no mirrors in offices you
know
you know i'm like i'm like i'm like i'm
like you know there's a better side of
this world you know like i would call my
friends they were fake all they would
talk to me is like oh i'm [ __ ] this
whole [ __ ] school who you uh and i'm
like i'm like when i come out you gotta
how do you see about me how do i i'm in
the most lowest part of my life i'm like
you're not asking me how am i so
my so-called friend from jail he's like
bro [ __ ] a mom i'm getting girls bro
i'm [ __ ] i'm like bro i want to [ __ ]
a girl yeah you know i don't want to
hear that you're not asking me how
you're going to ask me how i'm doing
like you know if i'm okay mentally
you're too busy talking about how you
taking this drug and you're [ __ ] a
mom at the same time they did take the
time to get on the phone with you and
that no but they did that they did that
because i was i've always been buzzing
and they did that just for like a little
like a boost and i noticed i was i was
being used yeah so i can tell you that
that in my case if i'm like
talking to uh a buddy of mine who's
who's in jail
like i don't know how to so hey how's
jail you know like it's not that it's
weird no it's weird but but
it opens your eyes man imagine every day
you get a 10-minute call from home
i guess i would say i noticed that
you're like oh you missed out on the
party of the life last night
you're [ __ ] sick out here not being
in jail really
really what i noticed is like you know i
really don't need a lot of people i i i
noticed that i you know i i got closer
to god and um i i liked i i you know i
missed my brother i wasn't around him a
long time and now my mom would put money
in the books and we would have
conversations and she knows that i grew
up as a man in there and you know it was
a good thing for me and stuff like that
and um that was that was that was one
lesson i learned while i was being in
there and um i just when i came out i
came out differently more mature and i
just cut off a lot of people and uh
you know did you both get like uh set up
and and [ __ ] forced to fight like as
soon as you were in yes it's called toh
you have you have to test your heart
because um you they want to see if your
[ __ ] or knife your [ __ ] don't take
your food yeah i found the second day as
soon as i so yeah did you win your
fights yeah well actually matter of fact
yes it did uh there was a kid there was
a kid that that they he stole a maserati
and he thought he was the [ __ ] and um
they said hey i like him over you and
when they say that when they say that
they're when they say that it's called
okay it's fighting so yeah so there's so
it's called instigating right so it's
like you know i
he says i like you over me and that's
see we're all good people though and
that's around a bunch of you know people
and they want and they're like oh
yeah
and i'm like okay i'm gonna see about
you and then you're gonna have that yeah
and then he asked me he wants to he
wants a friendly a friendly fade
and i said i don't do friendly faces
friendly face friendly fate is when you
you fight
but he wants to be friends out friends
so look i'm like i don't do that so i'm
like if we're gonna fight we're gonna
fight so i said i'm gonna see about you
i waited till night and when i waited
tonight i saw him brushing his little
waves he had waves brushing his hair i
was gonna stall you know i punched a
little bit you know a little sparring
session in the bathroom stall i came out
i walked very slowly i did a smooth and
then i went
and i punched him in his eye and he had
a black eye i mean it was stopped right
there the staff member stopped and
everything he's like well and then his
homework that was bigger than me he said
man that was a fair minute you trying to
find me i said what's up what do you
want to do about it you feel me so they
didn't like me at first but the next day
they when i woke up like you know what
i'm adapting you're a man bro you did
what you got to do so yeah
other than that i popped off on another
kid because he came in on some
double-sided thing he got popped off on
one dorm and when he came in here he
tried to snitch on the other dorm and um
they put some honey buns on top of his
head i want to go grab some food and um
he was sitting on the couch honey buns
honey buns or mp3 player they could play
music right
so they're not like actually putting on
his head they're like if you kick this
[ __ ] guys
you're getting there it's a bounty like
a gta bounty bro there's kids that all
their life in there it's called elbows
you owe them elbows so you gotta pay him
every time so he was watching he was
watching you don't eat he was watching
tv peacefully and i'm not trying to be
an [ __ ] but i'm keeping a buck with
you okay he was snitching he was
snitching on the other dorm saying oh
yeah they do this to do this that's so
we play friendly with them just playing
both sides
so you don't do that that's when you
come in and you stay quiet you don't
talk about the dorm so he already [ __ ]
up so the people were like i want him
knocked out so they put things over his
head and i said i got it you feel me i'm
gonna show i'm gonna show you all what i
got you feel me so he was sitting there
watching uh uh uh tv i grabbed to go get
some mangoes on the table and then i go
back and i just kept punching him 40
times he said
i didn't stop you counting or you just
asking i just didn't stop yeah dude i
would do so bad in prison i would yeah i
would everyone would take my food
let me tell you something um it's one of
those things are you really going to let
your food get took the whole time
i was
let me let me tell you something let me
tell you something
and i i like how you say that but um
it would be the kids like you that were
like um
they would try
and um you probably get tired of that
[ __ ] and and you try me no no no listen
like like they're like they'll pick on
you
and um it was still there was this one
no offense uh this one white boy
and um he got tired of it when he wasn't
playing no games and he was just like
you i i i get my food take this that
and um he gave
a big kid a beating
i could see paul snapping for sure
and just hold on let me tell you
something i'm not ready
i'm not ready he's drinking a [ __ ]
carrot juice no no no no and and
and and and by the way that was the best
fight i've seen the kid's whole face
you're gonna start hitting push-ups in
there i'm tired of this [ __ ] man i'm
gonna pop off on them
don't play with the kids that that you
think is [ __ ] they're going they're
going to do the fight i'll be a late
bloomer
it's the kids that run the program that
don't that don't fight the most
dude i i i was just lucky i guess nobody
took my food but then if they did try to
[ __ ] with me then they'd be told it's
not like it's not like county food is
good food anyways right and uh but dude
i didn't i would do [ __ ] backflips
for [ __ ] in jail yeah i mean even
though at that time i couldn't do a
standing back flip on flat ground i did
back handspring but i remember getting
some extra food for doing it for doing
that yeah people like that [ __ ] and yeah
that's like what david cho was saying
like if you have any sort of talent
scale you can draw you do whatever like
you get for hey when you guys were in
prison was that the most time you ever
spent apart from each other yeah for
sure yes yeah like other than that
you're like
oh it's always good
and before that like you guys there's
before you were making music where like
was there like art [ __ ] that you were
doing were you artists before no i was i
was supposed to be going to high school
i was on probation my whole time i was
still going in and out but i would get
released uh uh most time i do like 21
days 21 days there's not so i never
really went to high school i dropped out
when i came out uh i thought i was going
to go back to high school and what was
the call i didn't get my ged in there
and then what's it called uh i came out
and i got in a fight in high school the
second week i got kicked out they're
like bro high school did you win the
fight yeah okay
that's good there's a video of it but
when you guys were in prison were you
able to communicate like right later you
could not nope
so what was the reunion like like when
did you guys get to finally got released
when i got i got released first then
when he came out i mean that's when we
but can you send the kite
no no it's not like we were in the san
francisco no no we he was far away from
he was i was in tampa and he was in
duval he was going to go down the block
not to the next county
you guys were like what the [ __ ]
but i didn't i didn't miss them though i
cried a couple times the facility i went
to was a little bit more locked down
than his
wow
did you know where your brother was yeah
i knew exactly where he was at they
would tell me another thing he was at uh
um
um uh there's
there's golf there's gulf stream right
say yeah saint john say is uh st john's
a place called st john's county yeah
also over there next to saint augustine
i was in brooks i was in brooksville
academy and that's in tampa
and uh there was um
like somebody's like updating you like
eight year brother
the thing with his program is that they
would cut his hair see they didn't come
out here so i bought every week so i had
my pretty boy i had my pretty boy curls
so like you know people they cut my
curly hair off i lost all my so i had a
little bit i had a little bit swag there
you feel me that's a county rule huh
what like a duval county no no some
programs mine was his my facility was
private owned and the guy that owned it
he was the mayor of the the county in
saint john's and he says he wants
everyone every kid there to be bald just
like him so kind of like the guy in
arizona makes you wear pink underwear
yeah so like some programs some programs
what they do some programs what they do
is they flip you from opposite from
where you were
right so they want to make you into a
society uh accepted individuals yeah
like go get cut your hair and they want
you to feel as uncomfortable as you as
you can all right and i was
uncomfortable with that bone cut bro and
yeah they're gonna make you feel
insecure and they want you to
i know you don't even get no lineup it's
a walmart clipper they go against the
grain and it probably it probably hurts
it hurts they snag your hair and it's
every week but as soon as like i start
feeling myself and my hair's starting to
go growing back and i get to brush it
and stuff like that you know look
because i have curls so it looks good
when it's down and stuff like that i'm
like i'm feeling myself feeling myself
they know what i'm feeling myself they
come to the door
yeah come here boys
you're gonna probably get a bunch of
bald headed people you kind of was in a
program with a bunch of people with
wicks like i have now
so like that's kind of where i got it
from you know what i'm saying because i
was locked up with rappers uh hot boy
he's a rapper i was like so it inspired
me i was locked up with a lot of rappers
and stuff like that i'm like
man i gotta and at that time i got rap
you guys came here today with with the
manager how long have you been with the
manager uh this guy two months two about
two minutes okay two months yeah he's
been doing a good job yeah i mean [ __ ]
dude like you guys are popping off that
makes all the sense in the world that
you should have somebody professional to
take advantage of the opportunity that
you got yeah yeah yeah are you guys
doing shows or touring or coming up we
got a tour coming up i mean yeah we got
tours and stuff like that but we're just
we're very like i don't know we're
different type of individuals like i
don't know if you know how young boy is
but like we like to like we like we like
to we we brainstorm a lot at the house
we we like to do content and stuff like
that we're like building up our faces
like building up our fan base i want to
guys we stay focused we stay focused i
want to get as big as possible and then
we can do the tours and stuff like that
because
uh being like being on tour being on the
road or sometimes taking a lot of time
it's a lot of energy entirely it's it's
not it's not because you get to meet a
lot of people with different areas
travel and stuff like that but it's like
it's like you know i i like i don't know
what it is about content you gotta take
that tick tock thing for granted with
the algorithm and stuff like that like
did tick tocks the [ __ ] this is [ __ ] and
i'm enjoying watching you guys and thank
you
i love taking people people like to say
that we like
people like to like say that we kiss
each other and stuff like that
no no what do you mean you guys kiss
each other no no we don't kiss each
other of course but we but we play
around we play around with their heads
and we say that we kiss each other
okay like on a duet or something so i i
i i'll be like okay i'll kiss him for a
million likes dude like okay we want to
see that i don't know why they just ca
i don't know why they want to see two
twins kiss but i mean i guess it gets
the move it might turn them on
the uh
the the kissing thing i don't know
anything about that i haven't heard
anything it's not gonna it's not going
to happen it's just it's just a little
side thing that's it's funny
what
like you guys consider yourselves
rappers right that's the music you're
making yeah i look at things like this
i'm a very ah man i'm a very good
entertainer like i mean i know you guys
sing but a lot of rappers are singing
too yes i'm a very good entertainer i
i'm very good at making music too but we
don't close we don't close ourselves and
label ourselves just a rapper i'm gonna
be honest with you in the entertainment
world it's a lot of money
there i mean it it it can be and if you
play your card you play your cards right
i'm gonna be honest with you you know
the music game is dead a little bit
different uh music works off streams
like you you've done movies right yeah
like we would do movies like
we don't we we could do we could do
other things too i like i'm more i have
a business mindset so like i like
different sources of streams of income
sure so like i you know a lot of rappers
are good at being rappers
but i'm also good at being a rapper but
i have to multitask because i i'm so my
personality just like i just love
showing out that's what builds our cloud
up first is our personality
i just love it i don't i i don't think i
would have blowed up if it wasn't for my
personality well what came first the
studio version or the the rob
the jacuzzi
pool came first but you gotta understand
it came up in my head for in five
seconds one take oh [ __ ]
it wasn't fun it was it was it was more
like a peer pressure thing or you guys
were in the pool when it came to you or
you before and you're like no we didn't
thought about it it was a peer pressure
thing like i got laughed about it and it
was like something like oh so that
that's why you hear me say because i'm
an islam boy i was pressured you know
what i'm saying all right i was trying
to show like hey listen like you know
right you can freestyle raw and just go
viral i'm a freestyle genius you guys
are you guys are down to do like uh like
a island boy wild ride freestyle i mean
we don't we don't have to put him on the
spot like that no you can well what you
want what you want to do he's asking you
to come up with a freestyle on the spot
just like a little [ __ ] podcast that
we're doing right now what exactly
how about like you know how about uh
doing a podcast with steven let me let
me know that i'm old and you're young
and that's better for you
and what and what type of tune you want
the island one too
whatever you're feeling yeah whatever
you're feeling all right i'll i'll i'll
find a beat um
dude you guys are the [ __ ] dude
i'm really enjoying this
was that was the ufc dana white want to
freestyle
yeah yes you seen that yeah
i love you i've seen it we've done a
couple freestyles i love you guys yeah
they don't know why
they know it's the man i think he's
going to be on this show right dana
white has been on this yeah
uh what are you guys feeling an
aggressive type of freestyle i like
aggressive
jesus yeah okay
my bad advertisement
you want me to go first
hey look
[Music]
man
i'm just with my dog steve
yeah we turning like a [ __ ]
it's the island boys in the podcast
going fast with my cash on the dead [ __ ]
ain't nobody gonna stop me made that
[ __ ] [ __ ] go to running i go dummy got
some [ __ ] they gonna do it for me he
gonna die he gon slide he gonna ride all
day long hey
[ __ ]
i say [ __ ] i'ma stop murder season put
it down okay totem up on different
breeding blades i'm okay in that money
it be green street
steven pay widow steevo like we snapping
ain't no cap we seen it when i'm rapping
cause that [ __ ] really lacking i could
put it down murder season then we wake
them imma count that money to the top
and then i get some [ __ ] wrecks in
yeah
so much on my mind i be reminiscing
about the past yeah
trying to get that money trying to get
them bands here yeah i got sticks i got
sticks we gonna let it go i ain't never
folks i'm a mama man i'm trying to make
it i ain't worried about no [ __ ] [ __ ]
you could put me in a cell block i was
running [ __ ] i was hitting leaks here 13
years old yeah i was in juvenile yeah
threat follow me at 16 i ain't give a
[ __ ] yeah when i came out i was rolling
off a beating [ __ ] i knew i was chosen
hey yeah
hey
[ __ ] i'll pop another perky i be irkin
i be searching i'm like damn i put some
work and i was really in the booth and
i'd be spitting out my blues and i'm
like icy as
[Music]
i'm like body when he dropping imma blow
up by his top i just don't rap him on my
talk i be freestyling i'm well and then
i'm talking about my [ __ ] yeah i'm
watching with the group i got the aol 15
yeah it's talking two through threes and
i'ma watch that just because
i like
um baby girl i like taking perkies i
like hurting chest pain through the
night yeah shining light yeah baby girl
i'm bright like a star yeah let's just
go to world yeah popping danny perkins
in that lean bottle by the pine by the
dozen mean a stereo we be turned up like
a [ __ ] pull it to the club with my
thumbs man i'll show that pain off the
drugs and i ain't worried about no [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] get that cash up so stop on really
talking on them just they be some cat
puzzles
yeah
that was [ __ ] way good dude
yeah dude
i'm impressed by that i like it me too
we free stuff i mean that was fire yeah
we freestyle all the time we like we
just we just know how to rap it's just
the hate that people try to it is it
comes in us man yeah just i've been
doing a weird phenomenon that when
people saw you
they were mad for some reason like why
are you still polarizing like i i don't
i remember when i died can i be honest
with you though yeah if i was another
blue shoes i'd be mad at me too
just out of i wouldn't hate me too
i i'm not going to sit here and act like
i like yeah
there's reasons to hate me
i i brought it to myself i mean i i
tatted myself at a young age and would i
looked at myself in the mirror i'm like
i want to look like a minute so like
yeah so that's why you know
i'm unique it's not what people see
every day so the hate comes and it's it
the hate is real and the love is fake it
is what it is yeah so when people hate
on me i take it as like you're a fan
yeah right but guess what you're still
watching listen yeah more usually
get my streams up let's get this money
in me and my brother you feel me as my
team but then today you know we just at
the end of the day we know we're pure
and we're good people and uh we have a
lot to prove and uh and uh we're
destined to make it and we're dedicated
and we grind every single day and we
don't ever take no breaks as uh jeff
bezos said elon musk like the
billionaires man they do 365 days of the
year
they take no days off and i'm not and
i'm all for it you know what i've been
really fascinated by lately i've been
seeing videos about lil xan who was
[ __ ] huge
big deal making a ton of money i heard a
lot of videos that's so funny that you
brought them up today because i'm
looking at i'm looking at thumbnails and
they're and they're [ __ ] up they're
saying that he fell not fell off but
like
bro he's broke and he's in a hospital
he's in a hospital bed to uh i saw him
today in the hospital bed with ivs in
him or something like that
yeah i don't know about that it's like
night before last i i saw a couple
videos
let me tell
multiple times um
the
the kid was clean for a while
yeah and um
and i called him the last time i talked
to him i said um luzan you're acting
different and i'm like and
and he's like why are you he's like why
do you think i'm actually different like
i don't know what's going on you're
definitely out from dance again
and he's in the hospital and he's not
he's often stands again but but uh he's
he's i'm not gonna speak about his
business but he's off that cocaine i
mean cocaine and all i mean yeah
but yeah i mean the story that i get
from just like what what i see
is that his problem was
that he didn't have the work ethic he
did not have the work ethic and and to
be honest with as i called him
he's um
he's kind of a softy man
he he like it sounded like he gets
walked all over yeah he takes even
people take advantage of him and and uh
he
this whole blaming everybody else yeah
blaming everybody and he staged and he
stages the tana mojo dating him and
stuff like that he admitted to me i'm
like bro i i mean i'm not really
interested where's your head up it's
like bro
are you a lost cause are you a rapper
which one are you well yeah what was
particularly fascinating to me is all
these people
like i think uh
maybe one was he talks about his manager
there's these people who are in his
circle that they're saying that with his
g wagon he can't afford the thirty
thousand dollars to pay it off that he
just the guy's saying i'll bet my you
can cut off my arm if he has thirty
thousand dollars like he does he's broke
and
and i look at his instagram and it's him
like coming off a [ __ ] private jet in
a fleet of rolls-royces and i just think
to myself it's so tragic when people
feel that they have to maintain an image
of like a flashy card
listen admitted to me that he's not he's
not he's not an image he doesn't he
doesn't he's not in in for it for the
image yeah he's got face tattoos but he
admitted to me that he he admitted to me
i talked i had a long conversation with
him four hours five hours in the middle
of night but i think he is for the image
because he always have to be in a
mansion or something like that maybe but
he admits me he's like i'm a regular guy
i'm this and i'm someone i'm like that's
perfectly fine i still like that but um
yeah i mean it's uh the work ethic is
the problem the work i think is is what
everybody can agree on and and where
what you guys i mean where's the music
you guys
seem to evidently have a work ethic and
that's like the most important piece and
dude like what you gotta be in you
yeah what you just did for us with that
freestyle i mean
that's what people need to know about i
could do that all day all day long
freestyling
i mean that's you know i used to watch
um cyphers with a little pump and stuff
like that and he's making me laugh it
was hysterical i mean dude it's epic as
hell dude now
like when you you brought up six nine
earlier and uh said that you were
insulted to be uh
to be comparing that was before i was
even famous i was insulted when i was in
county and there and and the guy kept
calling me trippy red i'm like i'm going
to punch this old 40-year-old ball guy
yeah bro you can't call me trippy real
what's up trippy red i brush my teeth
should be ready yeah they'll call it
they'll call you here no they'll call
you different rappers you know what
trivia red is right i do yeah what i
don't look like trippy red why did you
call me trippy red cause you got tattoos
on your face so they immediately assumed
that you're right i have a four year old
man calling me trigger um
rap song he's working on i do have a rap
song i'm working on yeah see so steve
did a rap album back in the day it never
came out but it was like sort of his
downward spiral but now we're getting
getting back together for a redemption
now
we gotta get you guys on his rapper i
gotta use the restroom oh yeah man yeah
you know what like
how long have you how long have you been
on for we're almost an hour dude this
was perfect i got a show anyway yeah
let's uh
let's wrap this up um
i think that uh i believe that you guys
are likable i believe that you guys have
[ __ ] heat on you
i believe you guys have talent and
you're willing to work
and um
i just i'm rooting for you can i ask you
a question are you getting any tattoos
laser removed i did i had [ __ ] on
writing [ __ ] and [ __ ] what about the one
i don't know that one i i don't know i
was halfway through getting it removed i
was like i don't know how many penises
do you have tatted on you enough
hey what you should do is that's your
baby
when the next time we're
that's me when i was a baby
yeah that's me when i was very and dude
please stick around [ __ ] what what
what have you be the the our guest at
the show tonight yeah yeah you'll be in
good company i'll trip you the [ __ ] out
dude wait what are you doing a stand-up
show or something it's a stand-up show
but it's also like multimedia it's it's
got videos that are super [ __ ] up and
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
trip it's it's gonna be worth the time
right here right behind us you're
setting up for right outside
so yeah man like i'm rooting for you
guys um i think uh
you know i think it's up to you and i
think that it's gonna can i ask you a
question are you happy in life
it's a tough question because i'm hungry
in life i don't think you can be happy
and hungry at the same time i choose
hunger you choose hunger yeah i don't
want to be [ __ ] happy because i think
that's going to make me lazy because you
don't want to be comfortable with that i
got nothing i don't have time for it i
had that conversation get shitty with a
girl and stuff i don't have time for
happy you know i'm actually kind of
impressed that you that how long you've
been doing this that you're still uh
going uh like hungry and stuff like that
that's pretty good i don't have time for
happy i only have time for hungry you
sound like me and i'm out to [ __ ]
just accomplish it that's all i like
happiness and [ __ ] pay bills you're
you're a hustler but happy doesn't
accomplish goals i i choose the hustle
keep doing it there bro yeah they said
that the definition of success is peace
of mind peace of mind i mean i mean we
all try to chase happiness right
sure i mean like i'm happy when i'm we
we all know money doesn't bring
happiness it's financial freedom
yeah yeah i mean
but like it's good it's good to have
it's good to have yeah
but um you know you know you got to find
hobbies and be happy yeah daniel tyler
said i've never seen a sad person on a
jet ski
well being broke doesn't make you happy
neither but it's for sure right but um
but no other than that yo yeah and i
know you guys like i remember the like
the logan paul situation like i i saw
about that that was like i'm not trying
to give like advice to people who aren't
looking for advice
with the ones i'm i'm i'm i i i'm all
listen i'm modeling your advice let me
tell you what i'm gonna i'm gonna
explain did you see the way how he was
coming let me explain to you why that
was they had a motive let me tell you
why because
i i i i love when people give me advice
because you are someone that looks at me
right
and uh from third-person view and you
might peep something that i don't pee
you know what i'm saying so like i don't
have a problem with don't give me advice
it's the way how you come at me all
right and stuff like that and i feel
like he came at me like almost trying me
testing my number he made texting my
jewelry he made a gay comment already uh
in the beginning you're trying to be a
comedian yeah i watched the whole thing
yesterday it was he was kind of being a
dick i'm just condescending for sure i
only saw the one part so i just yeah you
saw the snippet part where i'm i'm just
being honest i'm just being honest we
went there with good vibes how we came
here and it's so funny he mentioned the
jewelry oh sell your jewelry go bro we
just upgraded our jewelry i don't know i
don't i want to go if i went broke i
wouldn't sell my jewelry but but i'm all
i'm like listen and everyone was like
why don't you take this right i i listen
i take advice from people all day long i
take advice from him i take advice from
him i take advice from anybody i even
take advice from people that are not as
successful as me like you know i like to
hear what people have to say about me
good okay
and these guys agree
no i know
but if you're if you're telling me in a
dick way like to sell my jewelry
that i wouldn't that i work for as a
young child maybe praying on my downfall
maybe if you go broke you can sell your
jewelry you know what else and you know
what else i noticed that i used my hand
i'm like oh at first they asked this so
how does it feel that we made it and we
were humbled by them we're like you know
we want to make it farther they
congratulated this at first and then and
then and then at the end they were like
so what if you guys don't make it so
they were they had a motive they were
trying to focus on that makes that makes
perfect sense to me and and i'm glad to
i'm glad that we got to get your uh take
on that you know like uh i i i
absolutely agree that like paul said the
guy was being addicted to that guy
though first time i heard about it i
clicked on it i skipped ahead just to
the part where you guys walked off just
because i was curious and i was like
okay and then he laughed and then and he
laughed he laughed at it uh after and he
paid us for a video to put on his
instagram all right so so that's what
i'm saying he had on tiramisu but i'm
just saying last night was the first
time i was like oh we're having them on
the show like i should watch this whole
thing and i was like dude these guys
[ __ ] rule and he kind of was being a
dick like yeah bro you watched the whole
time and then there's people that think
that we were being dicks yeah people
like being hard on us i mean because we
what what because we walked out and we
said that you know i said a couple
things or whatever the case might be i
mean i mean bro you made me mad bro it
is what it is i walked off and i'm
you're not going to play me like i'm
stupid oh there's a big difference i
have a i have a brand and i and i just
how steve was brand you know he
different ways of protecting his brand
just he has different different well
we're saying we have different ways of
pretending to bear and i'm not going to
sit there and have someone just clown on
me and say yeah i love it i love it and
and again i'm glad that we that we uh
got to touch on that and the the only
advice that i care to give you okay is
that i just [ __ ] don't want you guys
getting shot i'd like i
just wanna i don't want like we we move
we definitely
i i'm afraid of guns i don't like i love
you i love you steve
and i want you guys to be successful and
[ __ ] thank you steve yeah stick
around you have a lot to offer the world
dude it seems like like i mean i think
i'm 50 cents you guys remember when
people kept laughing at young thug
now it's considered a rap legend
because they used to laugh at his music
all the time you gotta prove it you
gotta bring yourself
four years down the road keep making
music they know he he's a freestyle
genius just like mika i promise you i am
do you guys have collabs with uh like
really big artists the in the mix that
seems like the way man we were supposed
to get a big collab with a big artist
nba young boy and it somehow ended up
happening because someone went in his
ear and told him not to do it yeah
all right haters so it is what it is but
we got you just got to move on you took
it took a loss there nba young boy is my
favorite artist if i would have got a
feature with him man i would have been
running up and down here but it is what
it is i got my twin brother we got to
keep on moving on yeah
maybe you do it in the future i think
you guys have the what it takes man and
i want people to learn how talented you
are yeah all right
thank you appreciate it thank you so
much this island boys boom thank y'all
now of course the island boys are gonna
be polarizing i'm sure there's probably
a bunch of negative comments in the
comment section whatever
speaking from my heart i can tell you
i'm rooting for these guys
i am man and i really did think their
freestyle was impressive you know what's
gonna happen with them remains to be
seen but i think that they're hungry i
think that
they uh
i don't know dude i don't know what's
gonna happen but like i said i'm rooting
for them i'm wishing them well i enjoyed
them and you know i enjoy you
the people who stick around
man the street team dude
i just really really appreciate you
that's all i got to say thank you